(Musique)
Allez, tous ensemble,
on frappe dans les mains.
On met le feu "Photocop".
"Amour paradoxal,"
"dommage collatéral,"
"mon cœur en décimale."
"Tu es loin,"
"et j'ai mal"
(Bruit de Disque rayé)
Eh, fais-nous
«L'orange du marchand»
Ah non celle-là
elle est pas de moi,
elle est de Michal.
Ah ok.
Parce qu'en fait,
c'est l'orange du marchand.
Alors, on est bien d'accord,
je suis pas Michal
Non mais t'es connu?
C'est pas ton pote Nikos?
Allez, fais pas ta star.
On avait dit 40€
pour la presta, c'est ça?
Ils auraient pu prendre quelqu'un
de vraiment connu,
genre Faudel.
(Chants "Qui as volé, as volé, as volé l'orange du marchand")
T'es vraiment une grosse merde.
Depuis hier 23h,
un forcené a pris en otage
les employés de cette entreprise.
L'identité du suspect
reste encore inconnue.
Mais merde!
Je suis pas un inconnu,
je suis connu!
Ok,
passez-moi le mégaphone.
On n'en a pas.
Le mégaphone qui est dans la voiture?
Ok, écoute moi.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux
pour relâcher les otages?
Tu veux de l'argent?
Tu veux du cash, c'est ça?
Non, on n'a pas le budget pour ça.
-C'est moi qui parle!
Ecoute moi, l'écoute pas lui,
c'est moi qui parle.
Non mais j'étais chanteur,
j'ai fait de la téléréalité,
je veux juste qu'on trouve
quelqu'un qui me reconnait.
C'est chaud.
-Ça va être chaud.
Franchement,
ça va être chaud.
tu préfères pas de l'argent plutôt?
Ça va être plus facile pour nous.
Non mais sans déconner
c'est lourd sérieux.
On a trouvé un négociateur.
Bon écoute euh ...
Bon écoute.
Je m'appelle Anthony Kimchil,
je suis le directeur des programmes
d'NRJ12.
Pourquoi il a un mégaphone lui?
Si tu relâches les otages,
je peux te faire rentrer
à la maison des "Anges."
Y'a plein de gens comme toi là-bas.
Tu seras très heureux.
Ça veut dire que je passerai à la télé?
Oui, bien sûr.
Et si ça se trouve,
tu seras en TT sur Twitter.
Ça...
Ça serait formidable.
Bouge pas! Bouge pas!
-A terre!
C'est toi Stéphane Lacoste?
Pardon?
Non mais là sur le magasine,
c'est toi, non?
Ben oui.
Oh trop bien!
T'es une star et tout.
Je suis trop fan,
tu peux me le dédicacer
s'il te plait?
Je vais demander un feutre au gardien.
Gardien!